oh the dying and the injured just kept
on arriving this was meant to be the
final push the search but the
revolutionaries have taken massive
casualties he told me that installed a
mild cases as martyrs of revolutionaries
inside a revolutionary said this man saw
a democracy yeah we don't say that smart
years we say mattress here revolutions
inside and he saw a lot of of did of
crew Gaddafi soldiers and thighs which
are spread in different areas inside the
cell yes doctors were overwhelmed
twenty-five-year-old Hussein he/she from
Misrata was just one of the patients who
needed resuscitation he died minutes
later
we've been here for the last hour and
casualties just keep coming in we can
hear the sound of gunfire plenty of
bombs is well in the background this was
supposed to be the final big push for
NCC soldiers but they are clearly taking
a beating inside search we've also
witnessed a number of casualties being
brought in with very serious gunshots to
the chest and also the head and here
inside the makeshift morgue bodies are
starting to mount up mostly from snipers
in very sensitive areas like the chest
and the head and the others were
blasting is all over you to Rockets
blasting all over the number adoringly
no but there are a lot they started to
increase from my o'clock until now the
numbers started to increase on these of
course adjust the casualties of the
revolutionaries it is impossible to
gauge how many civilians and Gaddafi
loyalists have been hurt or killed in
the fighting alex ross sea sky news on
the outskirts of Serbs